now most famous as Netflix a surprise
hit of the 2019 holiday season The
Witcher started life as a series of
fantasy books and short stories written
by Polish author Andrzej Sapkowski the
franchise's fortunes really took off in
2007 when game developer CD Projekt RED
produced the first of three smash hit
video games based on The Witcher it was
in the games that Triss Merigold went
from a magic wielding secondary
character lusting after the titular
monster slayer Geralt to a magic
wielding major character and Geralt
actual though occasional love interest
in November 2018 British actress and a
shopper was announced for the role in
the Netflix adaptation given the
characters contradictory history between
the page and the games fans wondered
whether The Witcher riders would lean
into Trish's romance with Geralt on the
series or return to the original text
and sidelined her in favor of other
characters on the first season of The
Witcher at least that looked as though
they were leaning more towards the books
with shappers Tris maintaining a
platonic / professional relationship
with Geralt and ultimately working more
closely with the sorceress yennefer I
enlisted a Witcher Geralt of Rivia ever
wonder where fate took him somewhere
unpleasant I'm sure no matter what The
Witcher team chose to do with Triss
Merigold for the show one thing is
undeniable the actress who plays her
looks incredibly familiar here's where
you may have seen Anna Shaffer before
Anna Shaffers first ever screen role was
in 2009's Harry Potter and the
half-blood Prince in which she played a
witch who couldn't land her romantic
interest sound familiar in the David
Yates directed film Schaffer portrayed
Gryffindor student Romilda vane the
leader of a clique of girls who become
obsessed with Harry orb rather with his
celebrity status and trail him around
Hogwarts trying to get his attention in
case you've forgotten the small details
from Harry Potter
Romilda vane was a small but memorable
character in the fifth film remember
when Harry's best pal Ron Weasley
accidentally ate a chocolate Coldren
laced with love potion and became
instantly infatuated with a girl that
girl was Romilda who actually made the
love potion specifically for Harry
Schaffer also appeared in the last two
movies of the franchise
2010's Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows Part 1 and 2011's part 2
continuation but her character had a
more serious purpose throughout those
installments
Romilda joins Dumbledore's Army to fight
against the evil forces taking over the
Wizarding World
but unlike many other minor characters
she survives the Battle of Hogwarts that
left dozens dead chopper has a
connection to another beloved British
born franchise one arguably even more
popular than Harry Potter and one that's
certainly been around for a lot longer
the actress appeared briefly on Class A
Doctor Who spin-off series written and
created by Patrick Ness the show
centered around a group of teenagers
studying at coal Hill Academy a
fictional school that has popped up on
numerous occasions throughout Doctor Who
and the staff who worked there on the
series which lasted only one season
champ or played Rachel Chapman the
girlfriend of main character Ram who
comes to a nasty end only for him to
move on to another love interest a
couple of episodes later so much for the
power of love
outside of worlds populated by witches
aliens and would-be girlfriends
Schaffer is mostly been left with minor
roles she had a blinkin you'll miss it
part in the widely praised BBC drama
fearless in 2017 and before The Witcher
she popped up in the background of the
forgettable British action movie I am
vengeance
however sh a perm an itch to make a mark
in a super melodramatic TV series she
played yet another troublemaker with a
deeply hidden heart of gold when she
took on the role of rebellious bully
Ruby button on the British daily soap
opera Hollyoaks from 2011 to 2014
returning for for guest appearances in
2017 and 2018 in typical soap fashion
shappers ruby went through a lot during
her brief stint on Hollyoaks a hit and
run in which she was a passenger a
foiled elopement that ended in her
fiance's death social exile and accounts
of all the bullying she'd masterminded a
cocaine induced heart attack and a new
life in Spain it almost makes dealing
with the respective armies of
Voldemort's the shadow Ken and the
notecard take out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stars are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]